salut à tous ces blacks m pour brut j'ai
envie de répondre en rapport aux cheveux
bon vous savez très bien qui je suis je
suis pas ce petit rappeur qui stream
ça fait des années qu'on me plébiscite
bien vu l'euro je te félicite génère de
la guinée à famille conac et lila
begging la famille je ne suis pas là
pour gratter des amis pas de lamborghini
bromont à miami alors est-ce que tu
assumes est ce que j'assume de faire de
la musique pour ados alors pourquoi
cette question elle est chiante bat déjà
parce qu'elle revient tout le temps tout
le temps tout le temps et j'y réponds à
chaque fois très sincèrement et on
dirait que les gens ils cherchent
quelque chose un truc pour me faire dire
que j'assume pas réellement alors que
j'assume totalement je suis totalement
bien dans mes baskets public que
magnifique c'est un public fidèle et je
me rappelle moi à l'époque où j'écoutais
les rappeurs que je kiffais ben j'étais
pas adulte j'étais ado donc ouais c'est
de la musique la musique urbaine c'est
de la musique pour les adolescents pour
les enfants les adolescents et ceux qui
veulent pas grandir comme moi pourquoi
je ne fais plus de rap me la pose
souvent cette question mais en réalité
c'est parce que je fais les deux j'ai un
public très large et j'ai depuis le
morceau sur ma route qui touchent
vraiment vraiment tout le monde
parents grands parents enfants tout ce
que tu veux et c'est ce qui est mis en
avant par les par les médias c'est
beaucoup ce qui mit en avant de moi
les morceaux large et quand je rappe et
ben c'est pas forcément ce qu'il va en
radio c'est parce que c'est parce qu'on
met en avant deux m'ont dit jean besoin
de mettre une étiquette sur ce qu'il
voit et moi l'étiquette c'est black m ne
fait plus deux mais ça me dérange pas
parce que c'est pas avec des morceaux
rap que je remplis mais tourné mes
tournées séquence est très large et
j'assume totalement parce que c'est
c'est ce que j'aime en fait - mon truc à
moi je préfère avoir mon public très
familial
je kiffe alors quand est-ce que sexion
d'assaut se reforme sexion d'assaut va
se reformer
le jour où il n'y aura plus de problème
juridique entre le producteur et
certains membres de l'équipe dont un
enfant